[Musique]
des tirs de tireurs d'élite nous sont tombés dessus de
partout quand une identification monte que dit le
médecin à propos de la jambe, ça va
mieux
et quand je cherche en quelque sorte l'œil,
monsieur le sergent d'état-major Montgomery rapporte
que la facilité
est-ce que vous obtenez tout Montgomery c'est
va bien monsieur j'ai une mission pour
vous Mangano je vous signais pour une
notification de sinistre le capitaine de l'équipe pierre
vous montrera les ficelles du métier cette mission n'est
pas simplement importante elle est sacrée je
ne suis pas un homme religieux monsieur
pas Dieu pas le paradis tu es un
soldat modèle dis que tu es un [ __ ] de héros peux-
tu me regarder quand je parle avec toi
apprécie beaucoup les heures de fonctionnement Oro
600 2200 heures me voici tu ne
parles avec personne d'autre que le plus
proche parent
nous devons parler avec mrs.  Burrell pas d'
ami pas de voisin pas de collègue ou de
maîtresse alors dites-moi de ne jamais dire des trucs comme
perdu ou expiré ou décédé nous
devons être clairs Nick dit tué ou mourir Eric
Martin a été tué au combat hier dans le
sud de l'Irak par un tireur d'élite
votre fils privé de première classe  je ne sais pas
tu dois y aller soeur heureuse
je peux rapidement t'informer d'une autre chose que tu
ne touches pas au N d'accord
c'est que non ce sont les règles
ce n'est pas le travail le travail concerne
autre chose
tu n'es pas lycée tu es  dans ton je
sais que je suis l'autre j'ai donné du sang fille je
pensais que tu nous regardais en ce moment
dis que tu es un voyou essayant de
profiter de ma folie